Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
I am Ferron cousins from Ring of Fire, sitting in
once again today for David Pacman. I hope David is
enjoying his time away. Meanwhile, we've got more
news to talk about specifically. I want to hit
on something that I touched upon in yesterday's
show. Yesterday, I mentioned that throughout
my entire lifetime, Republicans have not had
an actual economic plan that goes beyond let's
cut taxes for the rich. And I wanted to expand
upon that idea because I think it's something
worth discussing, especially since we're going
to be heading into election season here long, not
long out. In fact, we are technically already in
2024 election season. So it's important to talk to
people about what the Republican Party of today.
And over the last 40 years actually
stands for. And the answer is nothing.
The Republican Party stands for nothing. I know
they have a party platform. I know they say they
like small government, but then they they pass all
these laws letting the government intrude. I mean,
quite literally, to inspect your genitals. That
that doesn't seem like small government at all.
Yet you're passing laws, Republican Party at
the state level that will actually allow the
government to inspect your genitals.
Now, that's not very small government.
But here's the big point. Throughout my entire
life, and I turned 40 years old two months ago,
so I've been on this earth for 40 years. I
was born during the Reagan administration.
Subsequently lived through every other Republican
administration. I have lived in a red state
that has been solidly controlled by a Republican
governor and a Republican state legislature for 25
straight years here in Florida. So I know a thing
or two about having to live under solid Republican
rule. And I can tell you from my experience and
from working in progressive media for 19 years,
Republicans don't know how to govern. It's that
simple. That is the line. Republicans have no
idea what they're doing. What have we seen from
them in the last 40 years? And I use that time
frame because that's when the Republican Party
really kicked into this shift when Reagan came
into office. But it also happens to be the time
frame I've been alive. So I like to focus on that.
For 40 years, the Republican Party's entire
economic policy, whether it's at the federal
level or the state level, has been one idea and
one idea alone. Let's cut taxes for the wealthy.
That's it. That is all that party knows how
to do, even with their Republican majority
in the House right now. They've already
talked about extending the Trump tax cuts.
Yeah, we're worried about the debt ceiling. We're
worried about inflation. You know, the supply
chain shortages, the gas prices. They wouldn't
shut up about last year, but went completely
silent when gas prices fell again. None of that
actually matters to them now that they're in
power. The only thing they've wanted to do other
than carry out investigations and do stupid things
is cut taxes, make sure that tax cuts
stay there. Part of the debt ceiling
negotiations may include repealing or
changing of the inheritance tax again.
Because that is the only thing Republicans know
how to do. Think back just a few years ago, right,
when Republicans were trying to draft their health
care bill and it turned into a tax cut bill.
That's all it had. By the time it was finished.
It was just a bunch of tax cuts. Everything they
touch turns into just tax cuts because that's
all they know how to do. And it's not tax cuts
for you or me, it's tax cuts for people like
them. Because that is their economic policy.
If they had to actually sit and govern and deal
with the problems that they love to whine about
during campaigns. If they had to try to do
something about inflation, if they had to
try to understand monetary policy and how the debt
actually works in this country. They wouldn't know
what to do. And I say that because we're watching
them right now try to deal with these things.
And they don't know what to do. But it's not
just the issue of economics that Republicans have
failed this country on for the last 40 years. I
want everybody to to think for a moment. When was
the last time that a Republican majority. Passed
a piece of legislation at the federal level.
That benefited the lives of
average working class Americans.
Can you think of a single specific instance
where they did something like that?
Because, again, almost 20 years of working in
progressive media, literally researching and
doing things like this every day, I can
tell you I can't think of a single one.
Because they don't have one. We have seen them
bust up unions, which has hurt the middle class.
We have seen them ignore environmental
pollution and destruction, which is harming
low income and middle income American
people. They live in areas that are,
you know, tend to be statistically far
more polluted than where the 1% lives.
They have done nothing to make your life better.
They've done plenty to make it worse. You know,
at the state level, passing the right to work
laws, which is basically right to work for less.
Passing laws that allow massive corporations
to come up, buy in entire neighborhoods,
or buy up entire neighborhoods. Scuse me
and price you out of the housing market.
That's happening all over the country right
now because Republicans are letting it happen.
They don't know how to do anything about any
actual real problems. So what do we do? What
are we hearing this week? What is the biggest
issue for the Republican Party this week?
Bud Light. I know you've seen it. I've done my
best to try to not talk about it. But, you know,
sometimes you kind of have to. We've got real,
actual problems in the country. We've got a debt
ceiling crisis. We've only got like two months
left to figure it out before we have to start
shutting down agencies and programs. And you've
got Marco Rubio going on Fox News saying this
week that our global standing has decreased. Our
allies are now abandoning us because of Bud Light.
That's what Marco Rubio said. I'm paraphrasing a
bit there, but he said all this wokeness. Because
you've got men, you know, hawking Nike sports bras
and a transgender influencer promoting Bud Light.
Our allies are now like, whoa, we may have to go
it alone. That's what Marco Rubio said. They want
to distract you from the real issues because they
don't even understand the real issues. Like, let's
forget for a moment everything I said, that they
don't know how to govern. That's true. That's a
given. But I'm at the point now where I genuinely
think they don't even understand how to do it.
It's bad enough that they won't govern. It's even
worse to think that they literally don't know how
to do it. Which is why they pushed the culture war
B.S. on us. It's why we end up talking about Bud
Light for a week. It's why they went after
Eminem. It's why they went after Oreos and
Tuaregs and Nike's and Yeti coolers and Dr. Seuss
and Mr. Potato Head. I mean, good God, how many
things have the Republicans tried to cancel in
recent years because they allegedly went woke?
We have seen interviews with Republican, you know,
Trump supporters out there. Even some Republican
politicians are on video asked what CRT is. And
none of them can tell you. But they know they
want to ban it. They don't even know what it is.
And they want to ban it not because it's a threat.
But because it gets their low
information base riled up.
This is the same base that is getting destroyed
by these Republican economic policies,
by these Republican environmental policies,
by all of these. No, nothing Republicans.
And they just keep doing it because they're like,
Yeah, but we like the culture war stuff. I don't
I don't want to walk into a bathroom and see a
guy wearing a dress, taking a whiz as if that's
an issue that affects anybody on the planet.
But that's what they tell us to worry about.
That's what they want us to focus on, because
that is the only thing they know how to do.